Film Courage: How important is screenplay
structure to your overall writing?
Is there a specific structure you try to follow?
Jeffrey Reddick: I kind of learned writing
through a ton of scripts at New Line [Cinema],
when I was there I would read scripts all
the time.
I find that most of my stuff kind of falls
into the traditional three-act structure,
[Author Blake Snyder’s book] Save-The-Cat
thing where there’s an inciting incident.
In don’t get into…there’s just some
stuff…I shouldn’t roll my eyes at it because
people do.
But you know there are some books where they’ve
broken it down to the micro-science and for
me it’s just like too much.
In the way, you don’t want to beat the creativity
out of somebody by giving them too much of
a structure.
That’s why I think the three-act structure
is enough.
Yes, at the end of your second act, something’s
got to like propel you into the third act
and things have got to get more intense and
more intense to your finale.
I have a lot of friends who went to film school
and their one thing is like “I wish I’d
spent that money to make a film.
I would have learned a lot more.”
It’s not anything against going to film
school but if you’re trying to teach somebody
who is artistic how to…you can teach them
how to turn that into a format that is going
to be more palpable to the masses.
But if you start to get too much into you
know, on page 20 this needs to happen, on
page 30 this has to happen, then you are stifling
people’s creativity in a way.
There is a reason that there’s a structure
like that.
I’ve had friends give me a script and the
first draft is like 140 pages.
I’m like “I’m not reading this.”
This isn’t a script, it’s a miniseries.
If they can tell the Titanic in 120 pages,
I think you can tell your story about a woman
who is trying to find true love in her small
town in less than 140 pages.
There is a wisdom to the basic structure.
When I sit down to write something, usually
I start with a concept.
I’m very concept driven because I think
working at a studio for so long, I know the
concept is going to get people’s attention
or not get it, so I start with using a concept
and then I think of some scares as well and
then start building a story around a concept
is how I approach it.
I know a lot of people start from characters
and some people start from a story.
Everybody’s got their own personal kind
of creative style and how they work.
For me I always start with the concept of
the story.
I try to think of a concept that is kind of
high-concept where you can tell somebody in
a minute and they’re like “Oh, that sounds
cool.”
That’s where I start off when I’m writing.